seniors de pouvoir justement appuyer sur
leur apport et leur expertise qui
peuvent amener aux entreprises cette
société de conseiller de communication
crée il y a 35 ans emploie une centaine
de personnes dont une cinquantaine à
Versailles la structure va embaucher sur
une dizaine de postes dans les prochains
mois vous avez des entreprises ou
l'activité physique est importante et là
effectivement c'est sans doute plus
difficile de gérer l'emploi des
collaborateurs le plus seniors en ce qui
nous concerne on fait
95% de travail
intellectuel chez les clients ou dans
nos bureaux donc là on n'a pas de
problème de pénibilité selon le
ministère du Travail le taux d'emploi
chez les femmes entre 55 et 64 ans et
plus bas de 3,5 points par rapport aux
hommes elle travaille aussi davantage à
temps partiel